let's go right to the phones at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 we are going to start today
with our caller from the 4 8 0 area code
who's calling today from 4 8 0 hi David
is me yes it is what's your name hi my
name is Joseph Hey Joe what's up hey so
I've been a big fan I first heard about
you on Joe Rogan and just had a quick
question
so there doesn't appear to be any
official or constitutional mandate that
the incumbent president is required to
hold a debate with the opposing party's
nominee right Trump seems to gravitate
toward controversy and undermining our
institutions and we're seeing in
real-time how he's trying to propagate
conspiracy theories about the
obama-biden administration yep how
likely is it that as a strategy to
undercut by the Trump forgoes debating
Biden altogether listen he's hinted at
he can do as many debates as he wants or
none at all and it shouldn't be up to
the Commission on presidential debates
to decide that that sort of been his
thing like that he says he and the
opponent whoever at the time we didn't
know who it was going to be should just
be able to sort it out and do whatever
they want but that the Commission on
presidential debates shouldn't get to
intervene I think there's only about a
15 percent chance this is just me
pulling a number that Trump just refuses
to debate altogether I don't see it as
particularly likely especially because I
think Trump sees himself as winning the
debates for sure and so I have a hard
time imagining he'll really go through
with just not doing the debates but it's
not completely outside the realm of
possibility
got it okay and if you don't mind then I
just kind of maybe another question do
you think that with the lack of the
campaign rallies because of the pandemic
right now that it's going to hurt
Joe's chances of winning over voters not
on balance I mean listen the polls only
give us a snapshot of what's going on
right now
Trump's been failing on coronavirus and
Biden's just been doing interviews from
his house and Biden right now is doing
fine in the polls I think that the the
risk the Joe Biden is if Trump starts
doing rallies again particularly in
battleground states and Joe Biden
because the public health officials say
that this is probably not a good idea
Joe Biden abides by it that's where you
could see it start to hurt Joe Biden but
right now I don't think it's hurt him
and I don't think we can really find
data that suggests that it has you so
much all right appreciate the call thank
you